[Applause]
don't jump
thank you please please sit down
well thank you not only for being here
for what you did
i want to thank the vice president
harris
and the congressional leaders are here
today
you know
in a moment i'm going to sign this
bipartisan
government funding bill
but with this bill we're going to send a
message to the american people
a strong message the democrats
republicans can actually come together
and get something done right nance
and uh to fulfill our most basic
responsibilities
to keep the government open and running
for
american people serving the american
people investing in your communities and
investing in the american people and
doing it in a fiscally responsible way
this bill also includes historic funding
13.6 billion dollars to address russia's
invasion of ukraine
and the impact on surrounding countries
[Applause]
putin's aggression against ukraine has
united people all across america
united are two parties in congress and
united freedom-loving world uh
uh and uh this and it's an act with
urgency and resolve that we're doing
right now that you've provided me the
ability to to do
i want to thank the congressional
leadership for
working so quickly to to make sure we
have the resources we need
economic
humanitarian
and security
to continue our forceful response to
this crisis
we've already committed more than 1
billion 200 million dollars in security
assistance to the people of ukraine just
over the past year and i know all of you
know that it's preaching to the choir
here
but we've been providing anti-armor
taking out tanks our air anti-air
capabilities directly directly to the
ukrainian forces and we're also
facilitating significant shipments of
security assistance from our allied
partners to ukraine with this uh with
this new security funding and the
drawdown authorities in this bill
we're we're moving urgently to further
augment the support to the brave people
of ukraine
as they defend their country
and i'll have much more to say about
this tomorrow about exactly what we're
doing in ukraine
we're also going to be better positioned
to provide for the rapidly growing
humanitarian needs of the ukrainian
people
this war has turned nearly 3 million
ukrainians into refugees with numbers
growing every single day
and that's on top of the 12 million
people who require humanitarian
assistance inside of ukraine
the united states is helping to lead the
global humanitarian response with our
partners in europe and well beyond
europe
in just the past few weeks we provided
nearly
293 million dollars in humanitarian
assistance to people in ukraine and in
neighboring countries
our experts are on the ground in poland
and in neighboring countries where the
vice president just came back from to
make real-time assessments of a rapidly
evolving crisis to get urgently in
humanitarian supplies to the people in
need now
we're airlifting emergency
relief supplies into staging positions
in the region
supplies like high thermal blankets
water treatment equipment so that they
can be shipped into ukraine we're
providing essentials like soap and
laundry detergent simple sounding things
to refugees who fled absolutely nothing
but the clothing on their backs
we're working with partners to supply
access to safe drinking water into food
rations to the people affected by this
conflict
with the u.s support the world food
program has already purchased 20 000
metric tons of food to address the
growing needs of individuals affected by
this conflict
it's exceedingly difficult to get
supplies into ukraine while the russian
onslaught continues
but we're managing to get supplies in
ukraine regularly thanks to the bravery
of so many frontline workers who are
still at their post and we are
supporting food assistance at refugee
reception centers
in front line countries like moldova
with billions more included in this bill
for new humanitarian assistance we're
going to be able to quickly ramp up our
response
and help alleviate the suffering that
putin's war is causing
the ukrainian people and the region
this bill also provides necessary
economic support for ukraine
and ukraine's neighbors that are
impacted by this war
things like loan guarantees direct
financial support including
including to address the needs like
energy and cyber security
this bill is also going to help face our
our challenges here at home
it sends a clear message to the american
people that we're investing in safety
health and the future of americans
let me just mention a couple of
highlights
starting with community safety
we know what works to make our community
safer
and that's investing in prevention and
community police officers so they can
walk the streets know the neighborhoods
and who can help restore trust and
safety in the communities
the answer is not to abandon our streets
we're to choose between safety and equal
justice
it's in funding it's in this funding
bill
which we make sure we do both
this budget invests in funding for
agencies like the fbi and u.s marshals
the drug enforcement agency but also
includes funding for cops programs to
increase community policing
and the ability of the alcohol tobacco
firearms
tackle to tackle gun crime and it funds
entirely new community violence
intervention programs
just
at the department of justice
community violence interruption programs
are programs where trusted community
members
work directly with the people who are
most likely to commit or become victims
of gun crime
i had a chance to meet
with those leaders in one of the
programs in new york city not long ago i
saw the difference they were making
every
day we know these programs can
dramatically reduce violence and we're
going to fund a lot more of them
this bill also includes grants for state
and local law enforcement and crime
prevention programs
we're talking about drug treatment
programs school violence prevention
programs programs where people who might
end up in prison instead get mandatory
mental health care that they need
part of the safe before any crime is
committed
part of the safety is the ability to
feel safe in the gender base from
gender-based violence
i wrote a violence against women act
with many in this room years ago 28
years ago to provide protection against
domestic violence stalking sexual
assault
and to support survivors and help them
find a way out of those abusive
situations they were locked into because
they had no means to leave
with support for race right
rape crisis crisis centers as well as
housing and legal assistance
the law has saved lives
and that's helped women rebuild their
lives and make children a heck of a lot
safer
today
with this bill we reauthorize and
strengthen the violence against women
act for example
[Applause]
for example we're doing more to help
survivors or survivors in rural areas
and in underserved communities
tribal courts will now be able to
exercise jurisdiction over non-native
perpetrators of sexual assault and sex
trafficking
and we're providing more support for
legal services and for law enforcement
to get the training they need to help
handle what trauma survivors are
experiencing
i'll have more to say about the violence
against women act tomorrow as well
we're going to be able to fund
significant areas and common ground in
this bill especially in areas that like
that i call in my state of the union
address a unity agenda
the things that we can accomplish
together
democrats and republicans
two elements of that agenda
are one beat the opioid epidemic and two
take on the challenges of mental health
which have been exacerbated because of
the covet
problem
this bill supports opioid response
grants that are funding that we provide
to states to support opioid prevent
opioid prevention
treatment and recovery services
we also included funding for states and
support mental health services as well
as additional funding for children's
mental health services which has
increased exponentially
i've also called for increasing
pell grants to make colleges more
affordable and that is anyone making
less than fifty thousand dollars a year
they're eligible for a pell grant this
bill delivers increasing the maximum
pell grant by 400 which will make a
difference in a lot of lives
i'd like to add a word about another
investment this bill makes
one that i expect will pay dividends for
hope healing and for our economy for
generations to come
and it's called arpa-h advanced research
project agencies of health
this will be a new kind of entity an
engine for innovation a place where
we'll do the high risk high reward
research that can drive unprecedented
progress in biomedicine
it's based on darpa the defense
department's advanced research project
agency that has led to breakthroughs and
technologies that protect our national
security like the internet gps and so
much more
arpa-h will have a singular purpose
to drive breakthroughs to prevent detect
and treat diseases including cancer
alzheimer's and diabetes and other
diseases
and by the way
we're providing that we can and we're
proving that we can invest in the
american people in a fiscally
responsible way
last year the deficit dropped for the
first time since 2015.
it fell by
360 billion dollars last year
and this year it's on track to drop by
more than 1 trillion dollars
after four years in a row of increasing
deficits before i took office
we're now on a track to see the largest
ever decline in in the deficit in
american history
[Applause]
let me close with this
today we're again showing the american
people that as a country we can come
together
as democrats republicans and
independents and do big things
that our democracy can deliver
can deliver and outperform autocracies
and that there's nothing we can't do
when we do it together as the united
states of america
so i would like to now
invite up my budget director shalonda
young
and all the members of the congress here
today while we sign this bipartisan
government funding bill thank you all
very much
i'm next to you
no
everyone who's done this but you're all
gonna get a pen but we didn't have 18 15
pence up here so i'm gonna make sure you
get it uh when we finish
yeah i know i tell you what nancy
anyway i'm gonna give it a shot here
okay
all right
thank you
yes
[Applause]
no no you guys did that good to see you
man
[Music]
what will your message be in europe mr
president are you doing everything to
increase u.s energy production
mr president you have a message for
president zolensky
[Music]
of the death of tomorrow
in ukraine
mr president what about the covenant
funding
[Music]
no i was
president what message will you take to
europe next week
[Laughter]
you